ja also das finde ich auch muss man ganz
klar unterscheiden
und ich sehe das auch kritisch was
friedrich merz war von sich gegeben hat
dass das ist wirklich das geht es geht
einfach nicht mehr das also nicht mehr
dass das war lang genug leider so und
dass das muss jetzt wann das damit ist
das ganz schwierig kanzler zu werden zu
wollen finde ich auch das ist einfach
schwierig und muss ich ehrlich gesagt
dank das kalt dass das bei mir eher so
was
das ist so eine so eine koketterie eines
möchtegern junggebliebenen
das ist schon irgendwie so eine show wie
junggesellen gehabe das kann ich mich
wirklich ernst nehmen und ich glaube
auch die frauen die er da sozusagen mit
denen er da vermeintlich jeden morgen
telefoniert hat oder mit denen er jetzt
aufgewacht ist über längeren zeitraum
ich glaube die die sind so gestanden
die hmi können das auch nicht ernst
nehmen ich glaube dies oft einfach
nichts mehr weil 19 geburt sind ich
glaube das ist also ich glaube dass er
eine andere klasse also ich glaube dass
frau gut sich darüber über diesen satz
glaube ich glaube wir sollten das
richtig auf ich nicht mehr brauchen ich
muss halt kurz unterbrechen
rege mich so wahnsinnig auf welchen
ganzen ist ist keine lappalie das möchte
ich mal ganz klare märz über lindner und
im märz habe ich wiederum nach nur einer
aber jetzt gerade über den winter zu
kommen
es ist überhaupt keine lappalie ist er
sieht aus wie ein 12-jähriger und macht
herrenwitze wie ein 70-jähriger und es
ist bei ihm ein system das spricht für
eine art er kann dich an von man und das
spricht auch dafür dass er die art und
weise wie er frauen sieht wenn er immer
wieder hat sich die lacher solche
altherren schenkelklopfer auf die seite
zieht er um damit lacher zu generieren
wenn von einem parteitag das einzige ist
was übrig bleibt ein altherren witz bei
einer partei die umfrage mäßig im keller
ist dann muss man sich wirklich die
frage stellen ob dieser mann an der
spitze dieser parteien aber da freu dich
leider genauso sollte das sollte genau
die konsequenzen sollte sich die partei
genau überlegen wen sie da eigentlich
nach wie vor seit jahren immer noch an
die spitze lassen
[Musik]